[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: At that point
I will get out of the way
and let the talent
get on the stage.
ED PARSONS: The map
is, perhaps, something
that is going to be
a service that you
use on an almost daily basis.
ENOCH LAU: Keys are how you
identify your app to Google.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ED BOILING: A number of our
Code the Road attendees stay
on this afternoon
for a code lab.
And they've all gone away
with their own working Android
application.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Can everybody
get access to this file?
Put your hand up,
and one of me and Ed
will come along and help.
MALE SPEAKER 3: I could
easily build an app.
It was surprisingly easy.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1:
I love the event.
I think it's very down-to-earth.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: I like
to come here to the campus.
It fees like a second
home for entrepreneurs.